okay so the the the next topic is called
bagging um or bootstrap aggregation
which is an in a way of using trees an
ensemble an average of trees to improve
their prediction error and as we'll see
that the bagging methods well i'll
mention the bagging method is due to leo
brymen and it's kind of a bootstrap
process and i remember seeing my first
time i saw this what would that been
maybe in the mid 90s
i knew a lot about the bootstrap
actually i was a student of brad ephron
who invented the bootstrap and brad and
i wrote a book together on the bootstrap
in the early 90s
and then when i saw the bag i did from
from leo i thought this looks really
crazy um
usually the bootstrap was used to get an
idea of standard errors or bias but leo
wants to use bootstrap to get produce a
whole bunch of trees and to average them
which sounded really crazy to me and
it's a reminder to me that when you see
an idea that looks really crazy
it's got a reasonable chance of actually
being really good right if things look
very familiar
they're not they're not likely to be big
steps forward this was a big step
forward and took me and others a long
time to realize that and and bagging and
you'll see random forests that we're
going to talk about as well
they're used all over
and i just was at a talk the other day
where random forest was the primary tool
used in a big
image classification problem um using
state-of-the-art methods and random
forest was at the heart of it
okay so let's see what the bag idea is
so it's it's the basic uh
it's it's a way of of taking a bunch of
independent observation and taking their
average to reduce variance so just
recall if we had a bunch of observations
z1 through zn the independent
observations with variant sigma squared
now if you take their average the
variance of the mean of the mean y bar
is sigma squared over n so by taking an
average of independent things we reduce
the variance by n
um that's good so what what does that
say to us in terms of supervised
learning it says if we had more than one
training set we could
grow for example a tree on each training
set and take the average tree right
now that doesn't really help us probably
because we don't have multiple training
sets let's assume we just have our
one available training set well bagging
is going to is going to try to
achieve this now by taking not without
new training sets by taking bootstrap
samples to create sort of pseudo
training sets
grow a tree on each one and then take
their average
that's the simple but i think very
clever idea of bagging
so
we're going to take
bootstrap samples from our training set
of the same size as our original sample
that's the usual bootstrap
and i can maybe draw a little picture
here just so we can think about it
here's our original training set we're
going to draw bootstrap samples again
they're samples taken with replacement
of the same size from the original data
set
and we'll take lots of them maybe a few
hundred
okay
and for each one we're going to grow a
tree
um using for example the procedure we
just went over
to
uh on each of these training sets we're
going to get a little tree okay
actually quite big trees big trees
that's extra i said little tree but
actually in fact we don't need to turns
out we don't need to worry about pruning
the trees we can grow large trees and
just
when we average them we'll reduce
variance so we don't need to prune even
that's another happy coincidence so
in notation-wise we'll call the tree
that we grow on the beef tree again b
going from maybe one to two hundred
f hat star b of x so
the prediction at feature x for the b3
we'll call f hat star b of x
our overall bagged estimate prediction
is just the average
so so in other words we grow these trees
we have a new x and we want a predicted
x we we ask each tree what's your
prediction for x
um
and that's f hat star b of x and we
average the predictions and that's
called bagging so it's a really clever
idea
so you know the old idea of pruning a
tree back was to reduce the variance you
pruned it back but when you prune it
back you give it a lot of bias because
you make it necessarily just a much
coarser tree so
breyman's idea was don't prune back have
bushy trees which tend to have low bias
and get rid of the variants by doing
this averaging
right and we can apply this regression
or classification here i've basically
assumed we're doing regression so that
the the prediction is actually a
quantitative variable but doing
classification we can just do a majority
vote so we can
we can ask we can have 200 trees since
we have two classes we we we make a
prediction at each x
and we ask each tree what's your class
prediction and suppose of the 200 150
say class 1 and other 50 say class 2
then our prediction is class 1. so we
can just take a majority and vote among
the b trees that we grow
okay
so here's actually the heart data this
is the result of bagging the heart data
so
along the horizontal axis the number of
trees which we grew up to 300 trees in
this case
what do we see here well we have
um uh
we have the test error of bagging first
of all remember we had a test that was
set aside
and it's the black curve
um
and its error is around
a little over
0.25 if we go over the left here we'll
see actual results of a single tree
so in this case bagging improved a
single tree maybe just by one percent
error actually the dotted line is a
single tree right okay thank you so the
dot line's single too so it looks like
we may have improved the prediction
error by perhaps one percent not a great
win in this one case
um the random force which i'll talk
about in a few slides is a sort of a
it's a
more advanced form of bagging where we
do we
do another trick of brymen's that's
going to prove things here by maybe
another couple percent
so in this in this figure we've also got
uh two error curves called out of bag
for both for bagging and random forest
we'll describe it for bagging um now
so the out of bag area is a very
important part of bagging and random
forest and it turns out it's a free
essentially free way of computing leave
one out cross validation and it works as
follows
each of those bootstrap samples
includes
about
two-thirds of the observations and about
one-third of the observations are left
out
and of course for each bootstrap sample
a different one-third is left out
so suppose we want to compute the error
for a particular observation
well we can take all the the bootstrap
samples that didn't include that
observation and we just averaged their
predictions for that observation and use
them to predict that observation
well that's going to be that observation
wouldn't have been in any of those those
training samples and so that's a left
out
error estimate
and so you can just accumulate those
predictions in that fashion for each of
the observations and that's called the
out of bag error and if you think about
it carefully
if b is large the number of trees is
large that's essentially leave one out
cross validation and it just comes for
free and so that's what was given in
this slider so for for bagging that's
the green curve
and it's quite a bit lower than the the
the black
curve above which is the the
the error on the on the test set
um the green curve and of course there's
variability in these because these are
just samples of numbers and so that
variability um is just due to the
division of the test samples and the
training samples
okay so the the next idea that leo
bryant had a few years after bagging was
called random force
um
and the idea here is that we're taking
an average and an average will be lower
if the things being averaged have lower
correlation
so the idea of random force is to is to
build trees in such a ways to actually
make the correlation between trees
smaller
even smaller than you get from
bootstrapping
exactly right and again this is one of
these ideas which when i first saw at
least look really bizarre uh but it's a
very clever thing so
what is that idea well the idea is is
we're going to
do bagging exactly the way we did before
except with one change
when we build the trees and we make
splits
every time we consider a split in a tree
we don't consider all possible
predictors as we normally do with trees
but rather
we select at random m predictors among
the p and the m is say typically about
the square root of p
so in other words if there's 100
predictors in our data set every time we
go to make a split we don't consider all
100 but rather we take a a random subset
of 10 of them
and the other the the other 99 have
considered only the 10 are even allowed
to be considered for the splits and this
the random selection is made
a new selection is made at every
possible split
okay so again it seems kind of crazy to
throw away most of the predictors at
every split
but the effect of doing this is that it
it it forces the trees to use
different predictors to split at
different times
um and since we're going to build lots
of trees although if if a good predictor
is left out of the given split it's
going to have lots of chances in that
tree or in other trees to to make an
appearance so
although it seems crazy to throw away in
the sense
most of your predictors at every at
every stage
since we're going to build a large
number of trees and then take the
average it actually works out very well
so even with the same training sample if
you run this if you grow through two
trees you'll get two different trees
because by chance it'll pick different
variables each time
okay so let's see how random force does
in the
heart data
in
so remember the bagging error test error
was about here and random force
improves by maybe one or two percent so
again by uh doing this trick of throwing
away predictors we've decorated the
trees the resulting average seems to do
a little better and the outer bag
estimate
is also a little better than it was for
bagging
our next example is a high dimensional
example from chapter 8 on gene
expression so this is using the the gene
expression from 349 patients these are
cancer patients
the gene expression of 4718 genes to
predict their cancer class
and this is a common activity in among
people in statistics genomics to try to
declassification
into things like cancer class based on
the gene expression of genes and cells
so in this case there's actually 15
classes the one class is healthy or
normal and there's 14 different types of
cancer
so we're going to apply the the random
force method we just described to this
high dimensional data
but
instead of using the entire set of 4 718
genes we're going to actually going to
pre-screen the genes
we're going to choose that the genes
having the highest variance across the
training set and it kind of makes sense
to if we want to reduce the number of
genes to use variance because if
something has
small variants across the training set
is probably not very predictive right so
um choosing the one have the largest
variants are there are the ones that are
most likely to be predictive
so
is that cheating no you went from
4700 genes down to 500 genes
that's a good question is it is it
cheating is it biasing things well it's
not because with the outcome the class
is not being used to to choose the genes
it would have been a problem if we chose
the genes that that vary the most from
one class to another in other words if
we if we actually if we if we use the
class label to choose the genes
but because we're we're just doing this
doing this just looking at the overall
variance without regard to the class
label this is this is fine it's not
going to buy us our results so it's
unsupervised screening exactly so
supervised screening is a it creates a
bias in our
would create a bias in our cross
validation or or the outer bag estimates
but if we do it unsupervised it's no
problem much that's what we're doing
here so
um again for comparison purposes we
divided the data into a training and a
test set we applied by random force to
the training set
and
for three different
values of the m which is the number of
variables that we choose at each
each split
the the the the random number that we're
among which we're going to choose at
each split
so let's see the results
so again a horizontal axis has a number
of trees total number of trees we go up
to about 500.
on the left we have the single tree
results so remember we've been saying
quite often that the trees are
attractive because they're interpretable
but they really don't
often predict well and here we see a
case where they're predicting pretty
badly here's the single tree and it's
it's error is um
upwards of 50 or 60 percent now remember
there's 15 classes so an error of 60 or
70 isn't crazy right um
because there's so many classes but it's
still
still not very good it's interesting rob
how quickly the error comes down with
random forests
and then sort of levels off it doesn't
take long before it by about 100 trees
it's kind of leveled off and not really
changing that much
exactly and so and that levels around so
we look at looks like the best is around
well if we use um
m equals p which is just bagging right
that means at every split we're using
all possible predictors we're
considering all possible predictors
that's that's bagging those are usual
trees
that gives us the gold curve
uh random force the green one with the
square root of p so that's we're
throwing away uh we're
we're retaining square root p and
throwing the rest away
you see it gives us a improvement of
perhaps three or four percent over
bagging one nice thing about random
forest and bagging is that you can't
overfit by putting in too many trees
the only benefit of adding more trees is
it brings the variance down more but
that at some point the variance just
stops decreasing and adding more trees
does doesn't help you at all but it
never will hurt you so the by looking at
for example these outer bag errors you
can just decide when you've done enough